donc en direct de kiev bonjour joe
natale wolf vous êtes l'un de nos
envoyés spéciaux le centre ville de la
capitale et plus ou moins calme les
combats se concentrent toujours autour
dire pin dans le nord
oui écouter on difficile d'avoir une
vision très claire de ce qui se passe
sur le terrain et repine nous avons
essayé nous y rendre avec avec james
andré et nous avons été bloqués par les
forces de sécurité ukrainienne à
quelques kilomètres de la ville qui fait
clairement l'objet d'intenses combats
puisque quand nous étions sur place on
pouvait entendre des tirs d'artillerie
vraiment incessants et il ya encore deux
jours on pouvait accéder aux abords
immédiats d'irbine aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus possible les jours où les
journalistes sont bloqués à plusieurs
kilomètres de la ville sur place nous
avons pu voir certains des derniers
déplacés dire pin qui avaient été
évacués et emmenés au checkpoint nous
étions nous avons pu voir aussi sur le
bord de la route les corps de deux
civils dire pin qui avaient été emmenés
par lés par les volontaires du chrétien
donc voilà une situation une situation
clairement qu'ils qui se dégrade mais
encore une fois
d'avoir une vision très claire de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui est du niveau de
résistance des forces ukrainienne farce
face à la poussée des temps plus de
madame comment ça se passe dans le
centre ville de kiev que les frimas
alors aujourd'hui et depuis hier le
climat se dégrade d'après les services
de sécurité ukrainiens plusieurs zones
résidentielles ont été touchés d'après
ces mêmes services de sécurité ont
touché par des des tirs des tirs russe
impossible de confirmer pour l'instant
ces informations et puis la vie des
habitants de kiev tourne autour du
couvre-feu qui va être instauré ce mardi
à 20h il va durer jusqu'à sept heures
jeudi prochain et nous avons pu voir
devant plusieurs supermarchés de grandes
de grandes files d'habitants de la ville
qui sont en train de se ravitailler et
de faire un maximum de provisions pour
pouvoir rester bloqués chez eux et gérer
correctement ce couvre feu